we're being prepared for the end of the
world a cosmic saver witchcraft coloring
book
witchcraft coloring book bro this is not
like Hocus Pocus uh it's just straight
up calling it there's a pentagram Oracle
with the All-Seeing Eye On It tarot
cards like dude they're not
sugar coating it at all anymore
dude find out on this episode of LED
live
what's up
foreign
exposing Darkness
hey everybody Welcome to a special LED
live with Mikey Jenny and myself uh we
hope you're having a blessed week we
just wanted to share a little field trip
that we took uh and you know it's the
month of October so you're going to see
a lot of spiritualism around right yeah
you go to Walmart you're going to see
ghosts and goblins and bats and
skeletons and but this specific uh
outing we weren't actually just looking
at Halloween stuff this is stuff that
your kid can get exposed to just walking
through the wall the the Walmart yeah
this is year-round Stuff books toys uh
t-shirts we purposely avoided anything
that was Halloween specific because
that's just obvious we were looking at
what does Walmart offer that is blatant
just witchcraft
and it is pretty interesting because you
know kids are sponges and uh you know
they're paying attention to other kids
book binders and t-shirts and you know
things that that kids are exposed to and
so we just wanted you guys to be aware
of some of these things that are out
there
um because I think this is pretty crazy
that this is actually sold to the
general public yeah for me it's pretty
shocking because when I was a teenager
early 20s I was Gothic and I had to go
to specialty stores like Hot Topic to
find this stuff
you couldn't go to Walmart and find it
so to me it's shocking to just go to
your neighborhood Walmart and see
blatant witchcraft when I had to
specifically go to eBay and things like
this but now it's just everywhere so
we're gonna take you into Walmart and
this is a little bit about what we saw
even just walking around in a few of the
Departments check this out every time I
come to Walmart now when I go to the
aisle to check out I turn around and
right there on the front row of like the
clothing is all this Illuminati
symbolism on t-shirts I never thought
I'd dream of the day that clothing at
Walmart had tarot cards and all these
satanic messages but yeah we're gonna
look at that we're gonna look at some of
the satanic toys they have and the books
the books are crazy straight witchcraft
in here you know this is this is
something that is commonly at most
Walmarts I mean it's not just Walmart
too I mean I've seen this stuff at
Target I've seen the stuff yeah a lot of
other places so here we are in the book
section check this
look at this
Disney hocus pocus spell book a guide
dispels potions and hexes for the
aspiring Salem witch are you kidding me
dude aha I see you trying to look inside
my my beloved spell book this spell book
has been passed down through generations
uh of Sanderson witches wow this is what
Disney is putting out
spell book oh
[Music]
what do they have here
dude the elements air lightning fire
water Earth
this is Elemental witchcraft this is not
fairy tale pixie dust stuff are you
kidding me bro
[Music]
dude what
dude this is not this is not fairy tale
stuff man people like I think we're
making something out of nothing this is
really like witchcraft is real yeah and
they're putting it in the book as uh
that's something for kids man this is
insane oh yeah check this out
wait you want to do a little Seance your
kid wants to do a sales oh yeah they
could learn it from this book you think
they're not gonna read this and want to
do it
and it talks about like you know what
you do
the angering circle the calming Circle
dude this is straight real witchcraft
man Oracle orbs of water which this is
called scrying when you look into a
reflective surface to try and see uh the
future look at look at how like there's
even more
um witchcraft
is making a comeback because of stranger
things
Bell Jammers look at this look at this
the cute and creepy coloring book
and it's like a demon with little demons
around
like what in the world
look at this this is just crazy kids
coloring for your kids
what what in the world like a broken
mask how many parents are just buying
this for the kids because they want it
and they're not even looking at this you
know
what dude this is MK Ultra junk yeah
right
straight up
I mean spiders on your head do you know
that that actually is one of the ways
that they actually do ritualistic abuse
yeah they they will drop bugs and
spiders and things on people's heads and
then cause them to freak out and then
they'll have like multiple personalities
to think of Fear Factor is it just like
grooming for that oh my God it's
craziness look at this isn't the only
one creepy crayon this is kind of the
same
wow oh look this is actually real the TV
being uh yeah a ghost coming out of the
TV wow turn of the Gods and I don't know
who Nora Roberts is but we didn't even
see this book on the Shelf until we were
looking at the video one of the books is
called blood magic spelled with a K just
like Aleister Crowley this is super
occult and the other book is called
Shadow spell
who are the gods and what exactly are
they and could they be hidden agents
transforming modern culture even in your
life
this is the this is I think the masses
are being prepped through the media
uh books and movies and we're being
prepared for the end of the world a
cosmic saver witchcraft coloring book
witchcraft coloring book bro this is not
like Hocus Pocus uh the bad Wicked
stepsisters or something like it's just
straight up calling it there's a
pentagram
Oracle with the All-Seeing Eye On It
tarot cards like dude they're not
sugarcoating it at all anymore
dude are you kidding me this is actually
yeah isn't that isn't that the Ouija
board yeah that's the Ouija board right
there's a coloring book Ouija board it's
your local Walmart guys
what Israel look at this
oh wow
dude this is straight witchcraft in your
Walmart
that's from the craft the movie The
Craft
yeah I mean it's just like I Put A Spell
On You
anime starting to take off again
and it's just getting you know huge
yeah I mean look at all these look at
look at all these just like evil demons
and you know what in the world is this
is like d d players handbook
Master guide to drawing anime anime you
know Tolkien demons look at this
burn after riding all seeing iron burn
the book after writing oh wow
whack on the Titans
anime right there I mean this is this is
like coming down the pipe guys this is
all over the place another coloring book
with the dripping blood and just look at
this and just like dark yeah just
demonic this is weirdness oh my goodness
snakes and and creepy things on your
head dude what
man this is this is what kids are being
subjected to yeah this is stuff I used
and I wonder why people are getting
depressed yeah I used to really have to
seek this kind of stuff out on eBay and
stuff as a high schooler now local
Walmart come on to Walmart where you can
get your spell book and cast a spell on
your friends or your enemies like we're
in the kids section look at this Jackie
dude look down here look how dark this
junk is I've heard of this Five Nights
at Freddy's and it's literally horror
genre for children like that's what
they're doing with Owl House and dead
ends and all this stuff with paranormal
junk Minecraft zombies right there
Five Nights at Freddy
like that
and look at this as good as dead wow
star Friends magic mirror
see Mia's older sister is starting to
act strangely and the star animal since
that dark magic is at work can the girls
use their Newfound star magic to put us
up this is the problem people say oh
well the witches are usually the bad
guys but how are you defeating the
Witchcraft with witchcraft wait she's
acting strangely because of dark magic
but how are we gonna win by using our
star magic so you're fighting witchcraft
with witchcraft good like white
witchcraft black witchcraft there's no
such thing it's just all witchcraft
bad guys
amulet I mean that's that's something a
cult look at this guys we're literally
oh this is nice this is nice who is
Jesus there we go we've got one one book
out of all of them because they're
surrounded by aliens dragons like
knowing the animals okay there's a
couple ones there's a couple books you
know even with some of this stuff though
they make it like a fairy tale like the
animals can't really fit on the ark it's
unscientific they're you know you could
never fit all those animals look they're
busting out he's barely hanging on it's
just a little subtle way of just I mean
I like their artistic expression but I
think we need to make it a little more
believable for kids yeah
and obviously it's near Halloween so
you're gonna have this kind of stuff
you know there's a lot of Halloweeny
type stuff but if you just consider look
at this Pepe's Halloween party I mean
you like all of this is so dark and it
just gets kids it just gets kids
introduced to Witchcraft and terrible
evil things so like when we're looking
at the Hocus Pocus book everything in
that book was literally like
introduction to Wicca it was witchcraft
101 but they just put these you know
trademarked characters from Disney like
those three witches that's really the
only difference I mean you're turning to
it oh here's a a circle spell here's
Elemental Magic and and all of it is
just teaching you about witchcraft but
we'll just put these little characters
in there to make it seem more innocent
or more like a fairy tale or something
yeah what's crazy is it's like Hocus
Pocus is obviously a fake movie but
those elements that they're putting in
these books are not fake I mean there
are really people who hold seances
there's really people who communicate
with you know dead people and of course
they're communicating with demons this
is literally wetting the appetite of a
child and then they can go out in the
real world and see this yeah and like
when I was a kid I remember going to
Walmart and looking in the book section
I never seen stuff like this I've never
seen a coloring book that had these
demented scary images in them you know
you think of the fear that kids have
just to go to sleep in in general right
I mean uh you know my kids they've never
seen scary movies like that and they
like the light on and and you know it's
like there's already this kind of like
you know you feel unsafe in the dark
what is this doing to people that you
know you've got snakes and stuff coming
out their eyeballs and death and skulls
what is that doing to the kid's mind
right and then we saw the one Jesus book
but everything around it was like ghost
uh Dragons demons and the one little
book of Jesus and and the interesting
thing is I always bring this up people
accuse Christians all the time of
forcing our beliefs on them just because
we talk about it you're not allowed to
even leave a tract in the bathroom or
you're shoving your belief down my
throat yet you go down an aisle and it's
like demons witchcraft dragons ghosts
like yeah who's the one that's really
getting the platform to shove their
belief down your throat it's not
Christians we saw one Jesus book right
right yeah if you just look at it in
terms of weight there's a whole lot more
weight being dedicated to the occult
than it is to Jesus and you know I
wonder if the role was reversed would
people have a problem with that I mean
if it was like you went down the aisle
and you know there were like tons of
books about Jesus and the disciples and
you know all these good wholesome kind
of topics
um you know would people be like why you
know why why are we putting all this
religion out there for people but the
occult is a religion yeah and there is
there's like a you know a section that
Walmart has that has some like Christian
bugs and and shirts but it's like in its
own little area this is like you just go
to the book section and the majority
that's what it is yeah this wasn't a
aisle dedicated just to these things it
said books kids books kids books I mean
it was just like all through it yeah so
that's pretty crazy here's another book
it was called magical boy and it when
you read the back it says a
breathtakingly imaginative fantasy
series starting starring Max a high
schooler chosen to become the next
magical girl
okay so it's called magical boy but he's
chosen to become the next magical girl
there's this one catch he's a trans boy
dude you see at the bottom Scholastic
Books these are what we read in in
school that's what Scholastic means
these are the books that you order as a
kid when I remember I always liked when
I was in elementary school and you get
the little uh fold out and you get to
choose the books you want and uh yeah I
never dreamed I'd be seeing stuff about
transgender in there you know uh this is
kind of done in an anime style when we
walked around we saw like all these
different anime books and coloring
things and you know it was like they
were really pushing the envelope with
all this anime as well and these are the
topics that kids find in the anime yeah
I mean these are these are racy topics
for kids who maybe perhaps don't quite
fully understand how the world works you
know and it's like for somebody to be
transgender and this you know is this
like you know it's that's a that's a
heavy topic for a kid to to Grapple with
I want you to notice the the combination
of magic and transgenderism I'm not
trying to say anything but it's like I
see this all the time you go to Pride
parades and you're going to see a lot of
people dressed as Devils and uh witches
and things like that I don't understand
why you see this go hand in hand I I
kind of believe what I believe about
that but I just I want to point that out
so that others can see that this isn't
just my own personal opinion this is
really how it is that there's some
biblical twisting as well in the
beginning what is that that's from
Genesis right in the beginning long long
ago there lived a goddess Aurora she
embodied the power of light light being
like the first thing that was created
yeah because it even says it it was she
who shined the light on the planet
so in this book you're going to get the
inverted gospel like we always see this
is a that God is a female right and
she's the one that gave light to the
Earth and you know it talks about
they're being avoid right and it's kind
of very interesting like devoid the dark
deity I mean they're using these kind of
flipped upside down concepts of the
Bible right
um so here's where he first transforms
oh not my binder
I just got this
this is so unnecessary here he is I'm
yeah it's true this is unnecessary why
is this in a child's book remember this
is Scholastic books this isn't teenager
reading right Scholastic Books gets uh
shared to the elementary school right
this is what the Rand introduced to
right now uh hooky I guess is what it's
called like when you skip school I don't
know but you know you got a winch on on
a broomstick yeah and the wands which is
wands the magic books The Cauldron the
potions the crystal ball
and I I thought it was interesting in
this one that I was flipping through it
and this boy comes into the girl's tent
in the middle of the night and says I'll
get dressed and come out but don't make
any noise and she says why are you up at
this hour and he said to go to the
witch's Sabbath of course oh wow what is
a Sabbath from we say that in the Bible
but this is the witch's Sabbath and uh
she says no and he says fine I'll go
alone Dorian why are you so focused on
the Sabbath wow this is what Satan loves
to do he loves to take what's God and
pervert it such as the band Black
Sabbath this was a Blasphemous name
against God's holy day and here for your
children to read the only knowledge
they're probably going to get about the
Sabbath is the witch's Sabbath wow
that's crazy
so we basically
um left the book section and we started
walking around in just clothing you know
clothing kind of is very interesting
these days there's a lot of of messages
that are put on people's t-shirts I mean
that's why we love putting Bible texts
on T-shirts because you're a walking
billboard you're walking Billboards
you're you're telling people something
about your belief system so what does
that mean if you're buying something
with occult themes or witchcraft on your
shirt you know and I do think there's a
lot of people doing it unknowingly
they're just like oh that's cool I've
seen my favorite celebrity wear that
symbol or whatever A lot of people a lot
of it's just in ignorance you know but
uh coming out of that world I I was
immediately recognize these symbols and
I'm like why is that on products being
sold at Walmart these are the like the
the Walmart brand nobo No Boundaries
which you know the name alone tells you
there's no rules you know that's so
interesting all right so here we are
checking out the clothing right here
in the center look at the clock that's
behind it too is that like that's like a
tarot card too yeah look at this
look at this yeah stay open to the
universe uh with the moon right there
and ideas magic mushrooms dude you take
those if you're gonna open yourself up
to demon oh here's the checkered the
Sonic checkered stuff going on look at
this what does this mean like angels
with Suns and serpents and wait a minute
wasn't there an angel in the Bible
associated with a serpent in the sun
right right you literally Sun worship
you know dude everything's like if you
know about Illuminati symbolism
butterflies notice these patterns that
keep coming up there's like mushroom
everything look at this wild Hearts yin
and yang I mean these are these are
straight occult ideas oh dream Seeker
Wild and Free like you just think about
this Concepts that wild people are more
mushrooms
see the Bible says that our freedom is
in Christ like this he has these laws of
Liberty that when we keep those laws
we're truly free because we're not in
bondage we're not slaves to sin but the
world is teaching you no to be wild
which means wild is like you're not in
caged you don't have any boundaries
wild is to be free and the yin and the
yang this that was on the same shirt is
about having a balance of Good and Evil
we all have a little bit of evil in us
you know you just got to have a balance
of it but the Bible is all about being a
renewed creature having a renewed mind
being transformed and not not being
separate from the darkness of this world
it's interesting the mushroom thing
that's popped up because I mean if you
were walking around as a child with a
with an ecstasy pill on your chest
people would probably have a big problem
with that but a psychedelic nobody's
gonna bat an eye it's like oh yeah stay
stay magical with the universe you know
it's like those are drugs and just uh
clarify for people that the Universe
when you talk about that that's a new
age belief that you know it's like God
the unit it's it's the opposite of
saying God you say the university you
hear these celebrities talk about that
like oh I got to where I am because I I
just kind of let the universe fall into
place
this is a new age belief that God is
this universe thing you know and it's it
is not the god of the Bible it's
just this other kind of belief system
where you believe that the Universe just
kind of
it's like good luck or something you
know right right stranger things for a
kid look how look how they're angry and
upset but there's a lot of like dark
Concepts that are in that story that are
literally not necessarily for kids at
all so I find that interesting that they
made it a kids version what is the
rating for stranger things
b14 according to Lola lamb chops why is
stranger things rated TV 14 stranger
things 4 is rated TV 14 for horror
elements in language which means some
content may not be suitable for kids
under 17. but we're selling the shirt
for kids and the toys we're about to
show you the toys too wait a minute I
don't quite understand that though
so it's TV 14 which I would have assumed
that that's age 14. yeah that does mean
that but then why does it say it's not
suitable for anybody under the age of
17. right that means that they're per
they're putting a lower rating than what
they think is even suitable there's some
content in this show that's really only
suitable for ages 17. but we'll just put
14 on there yeah and what were what was
the reason horror and language I keep
seeing this trend of horror being pushed
to children not just in Halloween but a
lot of cartoons that are coming out like
uh that show dead end with the
transgender person as the main character
has the possessed pug dog it's actually
called horror genre I mean there's a
there's a lot of that coming out the owl
house is another horror genre for kids
yeah what I think is interesting is when
we talk about certain things anime
stranger things all that a lot of times
we get a response that well it's not
made for kids for one I don't believe
that there's an age limit on sin I don't
think that the Bible tells us to become
like little children to inherit the
Kingdom we must become like small
children if you are hiding your child's
eyes hiding their ears saying no don't
be in here we're watching Adult stuff
that should be a red flag right there
you should not be watching anything that
your children can't watch now when we
talk about stranger things and they say
it's for adults but yet you see it in
the kids section that's a child's
t-shirt it's like younger and younger
ages are being exposed to these more and
more adult themed type of content and
these are wicked wicked things that you
know stranger things is it's hard to
even justify sitting down and watching
one episode because there's that much
like just darkness and evil and weird
things in it and everyone loves this
this thing that's kind of alarming to me
too that society's all into this yeah
Satan is going after the children he
wants to get them young because that's
how he's going to rule the future you
get the youth because they are the
future and you get them exposed to
Witchcraft and messages like Satan is
the good guy and and God is the
tyrannical villain what do you think our
future is going to look like when all
those people are the of the leaders of
the world yeah and Witchcraft really is
a counterfeit for a miracle when
something Supernatural happens it's
outside of the means of our human
understanding we either have two options
to look at that that came from God or
you know magic what it does is it takes
the power away from God and says well if
I just have the right spells or the
right words or the right potion or the
right mixture of whatever
um I'm the one that's making this thing
happen so it's kind of like a selfish
view of a supernatural event and that's
what I think witchcraft is evil but
really it's just a counterfeit for for a
miracle yeah you're right it only comes
from one of two places so if you think
no I don't believe in the devil and all
that I believe in nature and mixing
these things together that's just how
Satan is getting you in he's got
different bait for different people some
people they believe yeah I'm praying to
Satan and he makes things happen people
who are more like afraid of that usually
gravitate towards the new age and
they're you know wearing crystals and
things like that oh there's healing
power in this Crystal no there's not
this uh just a satanic deception just
getting you another another way yep you
know you see a lot of these elements on
clothing for kids but you know if you
just look at the the t-shirts these
concepts are not like love your neighbor
do good to those that that hate you and
do acts of kindness I mean look at what
is posted on certain t-shirts that are
sold in these
um these apparel parts of the store the
minions they are always these ornery
little things right and them being
sarcastic like anybody like sarcasm you
know that's not normally a good
character trait that you want
okay or when he would like murder people
yeah you know Ice Cube is a gangster
uh you got like all kinds of anime I
mean stuff is just getting crazy in our
in our world
um I've never found anime at Walmart I
mean look at that once again stranger
things
you know yeah it's like look at what are
we what are we putting on our kids um
just like awful stuff that's now the
hero you know
just putting all these like super dark
occult ideas on our children that's
crazy
no not in the baby's clothes
get out and explore
and and I mean yeah like they're they're
prepping this thing heavy you know kids
content it's literally a demon in
Disguise look at that yeah goat with a
snake on it yeah
yeah I mean the the things that you're
seeing the majority of are these
negative things Chucky the the scream
mask the
uh these aren't positive attributes yeah
Venom is an anti-hero he I mean he's a
person that wants to eat people and it's
literally a possession you know he is
anybody who's got the suit on them is
possessed by that alien suit and uh yeah
that's the hero and there's a lot of
crazy things in anime we made a
documentary on some of the most popular
animes that were out
um a year or two ago or even some from
some of the past and uh if you haven't
checked it out maybe anime is kind of
getting more in in your kids's world or
somebody at school starting to pass
animes around and you really want to
know what it's about I mean check it out
we have the video for sale
um you could rent it digitally or we
have an actual physical DVD but anime is
full of dark stuff and I don't believe
any kid should be watching a lot of that
kind of stuff it's just awful awful
stuff yeah definitely not there was some
more uh clothes that we saw at Walmart
talking about positive activity and how
there's not any good positive things
there is actually a counterfeit
positivity and it's called you know
choose happiness but then it says Good
Vibes now what is a Vibe you know we
kind of throw these
slogans around we don't know where they
come from Good Vibrations this is all a
new age philosophy of if we just get our
vibrations right then the whole world
will be a Utopia we can reach nirvana we
can reach Christ's Consciousness
completely new age ideas but yet this is
what you see on t-shirts yeah you sell
the phases the school and him sitting in
that pose and obviously the word
meditations on there that's a mudra I
mean that was a um look at those hand
signs yeah those hand signs are
basically calling out to an Eastern God
and he's got the the Sun as a Halo
behind his head you got these Eastern
mysticism logos all over it and all over
on the other shirt you have all the
planetary systems and all that so yeah
you know it looks looks like a good
thing you see this over and over Good
Vibes Club Good Vibes and then here's
another
T-shirt with the tarot card we're not
just saying that we're not just saying
oh it kind of looks like this that is a
tarot card with uh just different words
on it it says grow together yeah it kind
of has that white bottom I mean that's
what a lot of tarot cards actually look
like yeah look at Patera card that's
what you're going to see a sun and and
the the little phrase at the bottom and
we're seeing a lot of this symbol of the
sun with the serpent and flowers and
stuff so it's like they throw in just a
little bit of
nice little things like flowers to kind
of get your guard down and accept The
Serpent and the sun worship and over
here what get weird Rebel or Rebel you
got you got pyramids all seen eyes you
have a pentagram On Your Collar yeah the
the alien gray head which literally is a
demon we have a documentary on the alien
stuff too
um the guy with the crossed out eyes
with his tongue out that means death
right there and uh but yeah you got this
in here love is the answer so it's like
the this is how Satan works yeah he
can't just come out in a in a blatantly
evil which now it's almost accepted that
way but he uses deception a lot of Truth
a little bit of error so you see a shirt
like this and you're like oh I love his
answer I like that I can I can support
that and then you're walking around with
all these occult symbols discover
yourself through inner peace
positivity and relaxation where are we
supposed to get our piece from yeah a
piece that passes all understanding only
comes from Jesus but this says you have
inner peace so this is really selling
you a counterfeit version of that that's
all the devil can do is really
counterfeit
um what God is promising I mean
obviously having a dove Dove is a symbol
for peace so you know these images uh I
don't think they're here by just random
chance no there's a lot of thought that
goes into this Celestial you are a child
of the cosmos a ruler of the Skies a
rule a child of the cosmos isn't that
interesting because you would think
about you know you're a child of God
who's the ruler of the universe but like
they're spinning it taking and removing
God out of it and being like the
universe is God exactly the universe is
God and and here we have another tarot
card looking thing with these runes on
there yep so apparently tarot cards are
just trend ending right now at Walmart
we have one here with the Sun the symbol
of the Sun the All-Seeing Eye the
Crescent Moon the planets the
butterflies one in the middle you know
they're trying to make it cool like oh
the skater it's a tarot card yeah and
then this one over here with the sun
these are blatant tarot cards not even
hiding it and what's with the serpents
and the All-Seeing Eye in a triangle
like this is blatant occult Illuminati
Egyptian symbology they're not even
hiding it serpents on either side of an
All-Seeing Eye and one that looks like a
tarot card with a pizza all saying I
with a serpent around the wrist this is
just insane like how do we got to this
point even the hands are in a gesture of
uh the horns the horns hand signs like
this is just blatant occult what is
happening at Walmart what is happening
to society that this is cool now and
acceptable
and here we see Venom on a kid's shirt
in the children's section so anybody who
says oh it's it's targeted for adults
it's rated R yeah it's on a kid's shirt
in Walmart and then here we have a shirt
that says hellfire club let's join the
club we can go to hell Hell Fire Club
yeah it's a it's a D and D Club on
stranger things but hey it's really cool
and trendy so let's just wear it so we
decided to walk around and check out the
toys because if kids are you know
wearing the T-shirt reading the books
what are they playing with what are kids
getting exposed to so we wanted to check
out the toy section check this out so
let's go check out the toys man they're
full of wickedness look at this oh we
don't want to just like rain on people's
parade we're we're disgusted that this
is what's being pushed to children look
at this this is straight witchcraft
magic mixes where you have to buy your
spell book your magic spells to to put
in your cauldron and you tap your wand
on it to make a little demon kid look at
there's a girl in front of a potion with
new spells
luck spell wishing spell and look it's a
book
this is literally grooming your child to
be the next witch magic eight ball
they've been selling these for a long
time remember they've always been in the
stores when I was a kid yeah this is
straight divination yeah straight
witchcraft wow
adorables villains wow they're so
adorable the villains huh
that what the Maleficent as the dragon
I mean this stuff's pretty dark for kids
it is really dark and and you know kids
fantasize they role play they take those
toys they put themselves in that
imaginary environment what are they
doing if you're putting yourself in an
imaginary spell or evil or angry or I'm
gonna hurt the world or you know what
what what is this doing to people where
I think we're watching our world fall
apart what we need to be doing is
teaching love your neighbor do good to
those that hate you and do acts of
kindness those are the messages and
things that I wish you know kids were
getting exposed to but this is this is
crazy dark you know kids they naturally
have an instinct to imagine and play
house and all these things but when this
is what's coming into the home they're
gonna gravitate towards that and they're
gonna try to impersonate those things I
I met a fan family when I was in Bolivia
who didn't have any dolls or anything in
their home and they saw their daughter
began to pick up like an eggplant and
cover it with a napkin and was holding
it like a baby the motherly instincts of
that little girl wanted a doll a little
baby doll to take care of to the point
where she used an eggplant so this is
the type of things that are innocent
that are training your child in the way
they should go to become a a caring
nurturing mother but when you're giving
them no get rid of that little baby doll
here is a cauldron that you can play
with and here's a spell book and why
don't you summon a demon as your little
pet friend it's just Madness is what it
is if you see just like a lot of these
like little girl dolls and stuff yeah
they're just Dark and Dangerous yeah
like what in the world or they're
dressed like prostitutes
rainbow high
I really wonder what they're meaning by
that
you know look at this
you want to be into heavy metal Rainbow
poison even the the packaging that's on
these packages has a rainbow Shimmer to
it yeah I can only imagine that they sat
in some corporate office somewhere and
they were like we just want to promote
rainbows you know and it's not rainbows
which was a symbol of God promising that
he would never destroy the entire Earth
again with water you know it was really
uh the the Earth got destroyed because
of wickedness and it's interesting that
the The World Is Now using the rainbow
as a symbol of defiance to God it's
Pride it's in your face God you know I'm
gonna live this way even though you told
me not to I'm going to do it anyway and
so you know this is a lot of deep
thinking that even goes into the
packaging of these little toys but if
you just take a step back just look at
the darkness that it is promoting the
the prostitution looking not modest at
all dressing well I just want to say
this is not targeted towards teenagers
how many teenage girls you know they're
playing with dolls right I don't know
any teenager girl that's playing with
dolls now these are dressed with
literally metal spikes black lipstick
yeah and mini skirts yeah the age of
girls three pubescent girls the age of
girls that are doing this they're
basically probably not even wearing
makeup at this stage right yeah and and
that's their model of what they're
looking at because you know if if a
children are playing with animals you
know like little cute stuffed animals
and stuff like this and they learn to
you know love and take care of and even
though it's not a real animal it's like
there's still some sort of like
compassion that goes along with that
when you play with these things you're
going to want to mimic and do what
they're doing yeah and we've talked
about this in the Magic Kingdom you know
like this is the first impression that
these
sponge-like minds are getting of what a
woman's supposed to be like Princess
Jasmine that's literally wearing like a
bra an Ariel same thing she's literally
wearing some seashells and and they're
getting the idea that this is what a
woman is to be like if a woman wants
something from a man well she can just
act like Jasmine did the Jafar and
seduce him and trick him and all these
things and oh I can get what I want I
know the message that that relates to a
young child is like oh if I want
something and I use my body I can get
the males to do whatever I want them to
do by revealing parts of my body to him
you know and even when she stood up like
that and her top fell off that's telling
a message like when the clothing comes
off you're gonna get your way the jaw
drops calm yeah this is this is madness
that we're we're and we and I think that
that you look at this kind of a thing in
society and you go there's no I wonder I
think why we have so so many messed up
marriages and problems in society is is
we don't hold the sanctity of that right
the sanctity of being a child has gone
out the window and now it's like these
corporate
Giants are making awful awful things for
our kids yeah and even the message like
uh you know find happiness and all that
it's all about if you're unhappy then
move on and do what makes you happy not
keeping a covenant and all these things
like that's why managers are falling
apart right we're just like look I'm not
happy I'm moving on yeah because it's
like the second that this person is
stops making me happy then I'm gonna go
find something else that is rather than
it takes you know work and labor and you
know a marriage is is is is it you have
to put the work in yeah love it's a it's
an action it's not a feeling yeah
another section that we wanted to check
out okay so there's these toys you know
that are pretty dark pretty uh adult
themed in my opinion or pretty occultic
yeah but what about the game section I
mean my kids like games do your kids
play games yeah she likes some of those
little animal games and stuff yeah you
know my kids are always want to play a
game so we wanted to see what kind of
games are kids you know have available
to them in Walmart Dungeons and
dragonish type things Gathering of the
wicked look at that that's crazy
Gathering of the wicked werewolves
in a world where everyone is wicked is
there anyone you can really trust yeah
look at this one doomlings the End of
the World the game
somewhere on a doomed and distant planet
life is emerging this is everything is
like this preparation for the end of the
world it's crazy
yeah my daughter likes uh cats I
wouldn't want her to play zombie kittens
yeah you know a card game where you get
to
um explore is that what it said or
explode when you the card game when you
explode I don't know it's hard to read
isn't it interesting how many things are
gearing towards this end of the world
all the movies I mean that's what the
trailer says it's the end of the world
it's the apocalypse blah blah then you
got video games that are literally the
same thing then you have even board
games they're saying it's the end of the
world
it's like it's like the secular world
knows that the end is near and it's
almost like the Christians are are kind
of backpedaling well it might be a long
time from now we used to be the ones
that were saying the end is near and
people thought we were crazy now the
secular world is saying look with
climate change and pandemics we got
seven years left yeah they're literally
telling us they're showing us a Doomsday
Clock that we're a hundred seconds until
midnight and we have less than seven
years yeah it's crazy
you know I really truly believe that you
would be best serving your time here of
really just educating your children
um in Godly ways and not just you know
this is what the world is putting out so
you know here you can play with this I
mean we should be careful guard well the
Avenues to the soul
um you know that your child can be a
shining light in a world of Darkness
like this
I'll be defiled be defiled like deviled
in a world of Warring sides we are all
be deviled between Good and Evil
side and Unleash Your how this fantasy
dude what
what in the world
you divide all right be deviled that's
how I would have said it'd be devil Wet
and Wild
wait oh yeah glitter liner in Bewitched
okay oh wait alien babe
wow dude so it's saying that there's a
war between good and evil which I
believe but what are they offering
that's good is it the Bewitched is it
the alien babe you know right it's one
thing to mention that there's a war
between good and evil but then also that
you should choose the good side not the
evil side glamorizing it it is they're
making it look beautiful sparkly and you
can be the alien babe yeah right or you
can just you know put on the Witch
eyelash stuff it's this crazy also on
that makeup thing it said wet and wild
like that was the name of some Playboy
thing when we were growing up right now
it's like yeah no this is uh just your
makeup at Walmart yeah the reference is
very sexual in nature and but it's being
sold as like oh this is just like you
know a little makeup makeup line yeah
this is this is very adult orientated
thing you know first Samuel 15 23 talks
about witchcraft it says that Rebellion
is as the sin of Witchcraft and
stubbornness as iniquity and idolatry
because you've rejected the word of the
Lord he's also rejected you from being
King yeah the Bible is very clear about
witchcraft it is literally evil and it's
it's connected to rebellion and you know
what I think is interesting is it it
even says that stubbornness is as
iniquity and iniquity is just
lawlessness you see what God says to do
but you say no I want to do it my own
way I I don't think it's really that bad
and God says that stubbornness is
lawlessness it's rejecting it's
Rebellion to him and then because it's
Rebellion Rebellion is as a sin of
Witchcraft so it's a whole cycle God
tells you this is what I want of you
because I love you and I don't want you
to get hurt and I have these guardrails
that are going to protect you if we say
no I don't want to do that I want to do
it my own way that's stubbornness which
is a rebellion and it's all business and
he says that he will reject you for that
that's right and he's rejecting Saul
because Saul did not listen to him and
do what he was asking God is asking us
many times in the Bible to steer clear
of Witchcraft sorcery divination any of
these things that you're seeing
um presented in this video it's like
there's very clear evidence in the Bible
that that says we should have nothing to
do with these things we shouldn't be
playing around with this stuff thinking
it's a game yeah so it says he practiced
soothing and Witchcraft and sorcery and
consulted mediums and spiritist he did
much evil in the sight of the Lord and
provoked him to anger these things anger
God because he's seeing his children go
off and and play on the Devil's
Playground he he loves us so much you
know if you tell your child you know
don't don't mess with that electrical
outlet and you see them go over and do
it
it's it's a righteous anger you love
your child so much that you don't want
to see them get hurt and you're like
what were you thinking you know that's
how we react because we love our child
so much and it says Consulting mediums
and Spirits we see this happening all
the time around us because the
Kardashians even
self-professed Christians are doing this
on these talk shows where they're
talking to the dead I mean
Christianity has lost its discernment
completely yeah and that's why we really
need to get back to reading the Bible
you know look up some of these topics
look these verses up don't just you know
listen to this one verse you know put
the video on pause pull out your Bible
and read the context of the way that
some of these verses are laid out and
the reasons why these things were said
and you'll find it shocking that time
and time again you read the Old
Testament the Israelites were constantly
getting tripped up with witchcraft and
magic and sorcery and following after
other strange gods and things and so
God's anger was often kindled because of
that well that tells me that if he was
angry at those people why wouldn't he be
angry if we're doing this today no
that's giving these little things to our
kids man yep first Thessalonians 5 19-23
says quench not the spirit despise not
prophesies prove all things hold fast to
that which is good abstain from all
appearances of evil and the Very God of
Peace sanctify you holy and I pray your
God your whole spirit and soul and body
be preserved blameless unto the coming
of our Lord Jesus Christ I believe that
Jesus is coming very soon you can see
the enemy ramping up his attacks ramping
up trying to to bring this no longer is
this hidden underneath you know dark
shadowy Corners good as evil evil is
good this is straight out in your local
department store from Corporate America
and we're seeing this on the TV we're
seeing this in the movies uh we're
seeing this all over the place in in
video games and books and games you name
it that's what it says abstain from all
appearance of evil when I look at these
things they appear evil the witchcraft
book Hocus Pocus the video games about
zombies and all these things we are told
to abstain from these things but every
time that there's a negative God always
gives us a positive look abstain from
these things but don't quench the spirit
despise not prophesies we look at
prophecy all the time prove all things
and hold fast why because we're going to
be we're going to be able to be
blameless when he comes there's a great
reward for doing these for living
righteously for abstaining from Evil we
get to inherit eternal life no you
cannot put a price on that nobody can
buy more time in their life we all have
a ticking clock and we need to make the
best time of this time we have should be
a shining light in this dark world and
try to expand God's kingdom and stop
wasting time on this Darkness yeah and
another thing that I will often
recognize from reading these stories in
the Old Testament is how patient God
really is I mean he really is so willing
to take you back if you've engaged in
these things you've you've you know let
let your kids play with all this dark
material or you yourself have even
gotten into it God is constantly calling
you back and saying just just turn your
heart back towards me just you know
leave this stuff alone and I will take
you back in a heartbeat and God will
take you back in a heartbeat
um he just doesn't want us to blend our
relationship with him and our
relationship with the Devil he's
basically saying choose me if you want
to follow me choose me if you want to
follow you know the idols of this world
then then follow them and I believe that
that call like what Elijah was doing on
Mount Carmel is the same calling for you
and I today choose you this day whom
you're going to serve you're going to
serve God or are you going to serve
wickedness in in the enemy of souls yeah
if you truly believe Jesus is coming
soon read Revelation it talks about
there's coming a Time those who do
wicked let them be Wicked those who do
uh righteous let them be righteous still
there's a line in the sand and darkness
cannot blend with the light and there is
no gray area that's right you're you're
choosing you cannot choose two masters
we have to choose like you said choose
to stay who you serve that's right so
Revelation 21 7-8 says he who overcomes
shall inherit all things and I will be
his God and he shall be my son but the
Cowardly unbelieving abominable murders
sexual immoral Sorcerers idolaters and
all liars shall have their part in the
lake which burns with fire and brimstone
which is the second death so yeah even
in the Book of Revelation the last book
of the Bible God knew that there was
going to be sorcery and stuff like a lot
of times people think man that stuff is
back in the old days people don't mess
around with witchcraft and stuff no in
the Book of Revelation it describes
those who aren't going to make it it
says he who overcomes shall inherit the
kingdom of God so we need to overcome
these things Satan is trying to trick us
into this stuff he's trying to see leave
us into this stuff and say look how fun
it is it's just a game it's just a movie
come over here let's play and we're
being deceived but we need to be
Overcomers that's right Halloween is not
just this fake oh just dress up as your
favorite ghost or whatever
there are very real you know evil things
that are attached to this pagan holiday
and it saddens me that you know
Christians are sort of on the fence with
this whole topic
um because if you just really take it at
its surface value it's like this stuff
is not coming from God it's coming from
the devil appearance of evil that's
right so here's another one in
revelation 22 14 15 that basically says
the same thing but I just want to show
that there's always a positive blessed
are those who keep his Commandments that
they may have right to the tree of life
so we need to keep his commandments so
that we can have right to that tree and
may enter through the gates into the
city but outside our dogs and Sorcerers
and sexual immoral and murderers and
idolaters and whoever loves and
practices a lie yeah it's interesting
that that word sorcery keeps popping up
in a lot of these verses and you know in
in connection to those that do not or
forfeit
eternal life yeah you know anyone that
practices sorcery so that ought to tell
you right there like there should be a
Line in the Sand draw a line in the sand
and walk the other way I just Old
Testament Leviticus we're reading
Revelation here yep Galatians 5 19-21
says now the works of the flesh are
evident which are adultery fornication
uncleanliness lewdness idolatry here's
that word again sorcery hatred
contentions jealousies outbursts of
Wrath selfish Ambitions dissensions
heresies Envy murders drunkenness
rivalries and the like of which I tell
you beforehand just as I also told you
in time past that those who practice
these things when will not inherit the
kingdom of God and I want you to notice
this about this verse it isn't just
sorcery yeah it isn't just witchcraft
there's a whole list of things that are
you know things that will forfeit you of
eternal life and what we don't want to
do is we don't want to pull out a white
white out pen and say you know what I
really don't like this part of the verse
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this and and blot
this out you can be left out of this
amazing gift that God's offering to us
for free simply by drunkenness so you
know think about these things this is
how serious this matter is to God and
he's telling us he's letting us know
beforehand I've told you these things if
you engage in these activities you will
not be part of the kingdom of God and
it's not because God is some Tyrant that
doesn't want you to have fun he knows
where these things lead to all of these
things lead to destruction drunkenness
it destroys your body destroys your mind
it causes you to do things that you
don't you would never do sober beat your
wife have a bar fight uh hook up with
somebody you'd never get with it that's
the thing same with sorcery it might
seem fun in the beginning but at some
point Satan is going to redeem what is
now his and I give I go on because in
Galatians 5 19 and 21 we see all the
things that you will not inherit the
Kingdom but the next verse says but the
fruit of the spirit is love joy peace
long-suffering kindness goodness
faithfulness gentleness
self-control against such there is no
law and those who are Christ have
crucified the flesh with its passions
and desires if we live in the spirit let
us also walk in the spirit let us not
become conceited provoking one another
envying one another see it's telling us
look all those other things we just read
those are the the lusts of the flesh but
we can have the fruits of the spirit we
can be indwelled with the holy spirit
that gives us victory over sin victory
over addictions in our life victory over
the things of this world that lead to
destruction and by doing so we will be a
shining light in this Dark World you
never know what kind of seeds you're
planting in people around you their
lives you know they might see hmm I
wonder why Mikey never does that thing
that we always do and uh
they'll really they'll start asking you
questions like why do you not do this
thing well because God shows me that
this is going to lead to destruction a
good test when you're maybe trying to
buy a gift for your child or you want to
buy him a toy or something like this
think about this verse it is this item
or this thing promoting a fruit of the
spirit love peace joy happiness kindness
goodness faithfulness gentleness I mean
are these the kind of elements that uh
you know whatever the T-shirt whatever
the book whatever the game or anything
like that are these the elements that
that's what it's promoting or is it
promoting death rivalry drunkenness all
those kind of things that's that's the
stark contrast that we want to sort of
bring out with this episode is really
um there's really only two choices yeah
you're either on the side of God but if
you just say whatever I don't believe in
God you by default are not choosing God
there's only one other option at that
point so we want to choose the things of
God we want our characters to be molded
in and patterned after a Heavenly
character trait and this is a great
verse to basically balance that and find
that out about that so we just wanted to
come in here and show you guys like this
is at your neighborhood Walmart you
don't have to go to some specialty witch
store to get witchcraft you can
literally go to Walmart get a spell book
you can get you know you can train your
children how to cast a spell in a
cauldron and summon a little demon
friend and uh yeah man this is why
Society is on a downward spiral because
the youth are being tainted with these
games they're just full of violence and
Witchcraft and we're just going to see
more and more of this as time goes on so
this is signs of the times Jesus is
coming soon I'm excited about that I
hope you guys are share this video don't
forget to like it it really helps get in
the algorithm and we want everyone to
know what's going on we love you guys
we'll see you next time
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you